hubert védrine en est convaincu les
problématiques environnementales et
écologiques et vont bouleverser les
relations internationales face à un
monde divisé et des enjeux qui diffèrent
selon les pays la sauvegarde de la terre
pourrait devenir la cause commune de
toutes les nations un propos que
l'ancien ministre du gouvernement de
lionel jospin a expliqué devant un
public est attentif à versailles par les
jeunes des pays qui ne joueraient pas le
jeu qu'après avoir signé des engagements
concernant le climat la biodiversité la
réduction des nuisances sur la
protection des espèces animales
protégées loyer et qui ne joueraient pas
le jeu après seront désignés montré du
doigt récemment la procureur de la cour
pénale internationale a annoncé qu'elle
allait se saisir elle même des crimes
écologiques
donc je crois qu'une évolution et que
progressivement ça va influencer la
géopolitique qui aura une diminution de
compétitivité écologique une notion de
crime écologique contre l'humanité etc
etc et pour établir un lien entre
écologie et géopolitique hubert védrine
propose notamment la mise en place d'un
pib écologique est une demande d'appel
je pense que les économistes devraient
signer de calculer en matière de
richesse et de plats simplement les flux
que mesure le pib déjà mais la question
des stocks
aujourd'hui on rase une forêt ça n'a pas
de c pas pris en compte dans un calcul
économique d'investissement classiques
200 personnes environ étaient présentes
pour cette conférence organisée par
l'académie des sciences morales des arts
et des lettres de versailles un public
convaincu
globalement par les idées défendues par
l'ex ministre
la grande idée c'est qu'il faudra
arriver à un consensus mondial
mais sur quelles bases l'établir sur
l'écologie
sa thèse c'est une très belle idée et
encore du chemin à faire
son innovation du pib écologique me
paraît très intéressant donc il faut
poursuivre mais ça sera un travail comme
il a dit de très longue haleine
à plus court terme l'accord de paris sur
le climat devrait entrer en vigueur
début novembre